I changed the world everyday.
I am an agent of change,
uh,
and hopefully positive change and that's
the way I view my work.
Uh,
when I say I changed the world every
day,
well,
how do we try to ensure that no child in
America goes to sleep at night,
worried that they don't have healthcare
coverage,
uh,
and cannot get ill.
Uh,
how do we ensure that every kids,
God given potential is fulfilled?
How do we use the power of our
collective intellect as a more powerful
tool than the power of our bombs?
And how do we do it in a way that
promotes democracy and human rights
across the world?
Um,
and how do we take American ingenuity
and turn it for good in other parts in
the world?
So,
uh,
what I get to do is work out everyday at
changing the world,
being part of changing the course of
events,
of being able to make the wind that
blows over our people,
blow a lot more gently.
Uh,
and at the end of the day,
I'm moving in a direction that,
uh,
says to me personally that I have left
the world a better off today than it was
yesterday.
Well,
change isn't always easy and it doesn't
always happen.
And sometimes I wonder,
did I leave the world better off today
than it was yesterday?
Uh,
but,
uh,
but bringing people together in common
cause is a great challenge.
Also great opportunity to do great
things.
Um,
and obviously that's a,
that's a struggle because we don't all
come from the same experiences,
come from the same backgrounds,
look at everything the same way even
when sometimes we believe in a common
goal,
but we have different views as to how we
achieve them.
And so,
uh,
that's a struggle.
It's a struggle from someone who grew up
poor,
uh,
to be in an institution which getting
there often,
uh,
requires,
for example,
raising money,
uh,
to,
expanding very expensive elections in
media markets that are very expensive so
that you can get your message so that of
what you want to do so that you can be
elected to then do the things that will
change the course of events.
And,
and that's,
that's a struggle.
Hi.
I think I'm best known for,
um,
trying to give Hispanic Americans a
place at the table,
particularly as it relates to a,
um,
being part of the political space in our
country.
Uh,
empowering seeking to empower Latino's,
which I've done from my home state of
New Jersey,
had been involved with nationally,
uh,
and also riveting attention,
within the fastest part of America's
population growth and the largest single
minority that there is a great
potential,
not just for that community itself,
but for the broader American community.
Um,
this is a community that is a younger by
a decade and the rest of the population,
uh,
and so as the nation grays and grows
older,
it will increasingly look to members of
this community within the American
family for the quality of their lives.
Some of us will be washing a surgeons,
I mean a,
a kitchen knife in a,
uh,
in a restaurant.
And another one of us will be holding a
surgeon's knife in an operating room and
how well educated and trained that
individual will be will be increasingly
important to those who are going to be
his or her patients.
And so if we are younger by a decade,
uh,
and uh,
going to be about 25 percent of all of
the nations schoolchildren within the
next 20 years,
it means the educational future of the
nation is also at stake in large part to
this community.
Uh,
and so how well educated that a part of
American society is going to be
important for the nations competitive
future.
So having Hispanic Americans play a
significant role in having policy issues
that affect the quality of their lives,
that in return,
therefore,
the quality of opportunity in America is
something that I think that not only
have I been doing,
but that I am known for in terms of part
of my work.
It would be that,
uh,
it is a sleeping giant that I think is
about to awaken and needs to wake up and
needs to wake up by using its electoral
power in a way that can decide the
course of events,
uh,
immediately in our country.
And for the longterm,
I think the community has a
transformational opportunity to change
and impact not only,
for example,
who the next president of the United
States will be,
which in and of itself will be
significant.
But where public policy will head when
you have 17 million Latinos in the
country,
uh,
who are eligible to vote.
And when you see where they're located
in the states that are critical for an
electoral victory,
for the next president of the United
States,
you have an opportunity,
uh,
to have a transformational change by the
use of your power,
our challenge,
my message to the community that would
be,
you've got to use that power because
that power ultimately comes back in the
things that you care about,
for the future of your family,
for the future of the community that you
live in,
the nation that you call your own
Giotto,
Latina decade,
a dealing room,
bullet in life,
Doria that allow both the full tool,
that device in a bladed that acc at the
median is the baton.
This gang,
the moment to voiding the city kimball,
Proximo,
presidente battle,
the Wallace sloppily,
Deca,
Domestica,
internacional.
They get pulled a muscle or rather
lacking,
get to the.
And I want to maintain a point instead
of the city though for the looser than
northrop audit,
Elo Unico embedding to it,
but is to trump material and acquire
good parents like the name of etc.
It a solid support that focus you have,
someone has supported,
considered below hit have club,
but a proximal president for them,
but he wound up political domestica do
this,
evaporated fairly sudden news,
very different in the house of
representatives and institution of 435
people that is incredibly diverse.
Uh,
gettIng uh,
enough people in common cause 218 people
to pass anything is a real challenge.
But particularly,
uh,
one of the big differences between the
house and the senate as if you're in the
house of representatives and if you
happen to be in the minority party,
whenever that might be,
whether it's republicans or democrats in
the past,
it's almost an abject minority because
the rules of the house control the
process in such a way that the majority
largely controls everything primarily
through a traffic cop call that rules
committee.
And in doing so,
that committee,
which is a super majority of the
majority of controls,
what gets to the floor of the house of
representatives under what way?
It's debated how much time,
what amendments and all that.
So,
and,
and it can even change the legislation
that you may have gotten out of another
committee that,
uh,
ultimately comes before the rules
committee.
The rules committee can say,
you know what,
we're going to rewrite this bill and
we're going to send it to the floor in a
different way.
so in the house of representatives,
not only is getting common cause and
much more difficult challenge because
you knew 218 votes,
but you also have the differences
between a majority and a minority with
the minority facing enormous hurdles to
have its views or propositions be voted
on in the United States senate.
Not only of course is that a smaller
institution,
100 members,
but the power is given to an individual
senator can make a minority senator,
uh,
one in which they play a majority role.
Uh,
and because there is no traffic cop,
the rules committee and so much moves in
the senate by what we call unanimous
consent,
which just means that there has to be
unanimity among 100 members to let
something move forward.
And one senator can get up and object.
And I had an early experience of that
upon coming to the senate where there
was a legislation in the final days of
the republican senate in 2006 that
wanted to change and authorize a Ryan
White funding,
which is important about aids prevention
and,
uh,
and the,
how we help the hiv affected community.
And it was going to be done in such a
way that clearly would have hurt my
state of New Jersey,
uh,
in ways that I could not tolerate on
behalf of that community.
And it was my power then as a minor part
of the minority power party.
But as an individual senator to say I
object and by my objections stopping a
process that until a negotiation took
place with me that changed the course of
events at made that legislation in its
reauthorization far more acceptable to
those people who have suffered with hiv
aids in my home state of New Jersey.
And it's an example of how even a,
a member of the minority party in the
senate can have a disproportionate
opportunity to affect the course of
events than a minority member of the
house.
Of representatives,
maybe not as many as I'd like since it
is one of those books that inspire me.
Uh,
but there are moments,
there are moments.
I think there are moments,
people who are the party of the
president and are willing to buck the
president.
Uh,
and that is,
I think a,
a,
a profile encouraged.
There are those people who are willing
to speak out against a,
what might be seen as the popular view
in a country or among their colleagues.
And I know last year I know I was only
one of 12 members,
uh,
to vote to transition out of Iraq,
out of 100 member body and,
uh,
you know,
um,
for a lot of,
uh,
those individuals,
that was not an easy choice,
but they felt it was the right choice.
Um,
and so there are moments of that,
you know,
um,
uh,
I think though that,
um,
to say what is one person's profile
encourage,
uh,
may not be seen as significant as
another's.
But,
uh,
um,
I think passage from profiles and
courage that speaks to this is a,
in a prologue which says,
in whatever arena of life what meets the
challenge of courage,
no matter the sacrifices they face,
if they follow their conscience,
the loss of their friends,
their fortune,
their contentment,
even the esteem of their fellow man,
each person must decide for themselves
the course they will follow,
the stories of past courage they can
teach,
they can offer hope,
they can provide inspiration,
but they cannot provide courage itself
for this.
Each person must look into their own
soul.
And I think there are members of the
senate in their own ways on different
issues who,
uh,
from time to time look into their own
soul and act in a way that is
courageous.